février enlèvement du juge d'aix de lyon
le dossier de notre envoyé spécial
françois corner drogue après la
découverte et du laboratoire de la
ciotat les nationaux des nations unies
affirme définir sur constitue dans le
monde entier
l'enquète de patrick clément en
thaïlande et là messieurs bonsoir ça
commence bien pour l'équipe de france de
football si elle confirme en argentine
l'excellent résultats qu'elle a obtenus
cet après midi à naples face aux
italiens match nul 2 partout
eh bien les tricolores iront loin en
coupe du monde car ce sont ces mêmes
italiens qu'ils vont retrouver dans leur
poule les italiens jusqu'alors considéré
comme favori il va réussir le partage
des points sur leur terrain
c'est une bien jolie performance que
nous saluons avec hervé duthu
après un début de match assez et dans
les deux équipes nous avons gens à n'en
pas douter à leur premier match de coupe
du monde les italiens en bleu à droite
vont prendre rapidement l'ascendant sur
les français en cette première mi temps
aidé il est vrai par l'arbitré monsieur
martinez ti siffler dès la 13e minute un
penalty discutable ou ralentis voici
l'action tour délit remonte tout le
terrain et est taclé semble-t-il
régulièrement par meyer marius trésor
toujours est il que monsieur martinez en
décide autrement et grazziani ne se fait
pas faute de marquer le premier but
italien après ce coup du sort les
joueurs français ont malheureusement se
montrer maladroit et à la 22e minute ils
encaissent un deuxième but
un débordement de claudio salah qui
fasse view un centre et grazziani
reprend de la tête
inna au ralenti voyons de nouveaux ce
but et notons la faute de la défense
française qui laisse l'avant centre
italien absolument seul à six mètres du
but de ré 2 à 0 ce sera le score à la mi
temps après une nette domination
italienne
les joueurs français vont pourtant
réagir après la pause et réduire le
score à la 51e minute à la suite de ce
corner tiré par le strasbourgeois
guemriche bathenay de la tête prend le
gardien of complètement à contre-pied
à partir de cet instant les français
vont dominer jusqu'à la fin de la
rencontre
et puis vous pouviez vous en doutez
commence aussi le festival latino 63e
minute coup franc pour les français à 22
mètres des buts italiens aplatir et font
déjà
mais l'arbitré refuse de vue car il
n'avait pas autorisé le tir
81e minute platini faucher la limite de
la surface de réparation l'arbitré
siffle un nouveau coup franc cette fois
platini le tir sur la droite jock
pourtant réputé comme l'un des meilleurs
gardiens du monde
et puis à conforter de partout ce sera
le score final mais pour le plaisir il
faut l'avouer avec une poigne de
chauvinisme je vous laisse admirer une
dernière fois le but de celui qu'on me
clubs les plus prestigieux souhaite
s'attacher les services
bien beau but mais peut être pu voir ce
match en direct sur notre antenne à 15
heures et d'après les enquêtes que nous
avons menées si une bonne partie de la
france et par était de travailler en ce
début d'après midi
regardez ce qui s'est passé par exemple
dans cette petite entreprise
d'import-export de surcroît
franco-italienne ce qui n'arrangeait
rien on ne donne pas de péno à nabeul
si vous avez essayé d'appeler cette
entreprise entre 3h et 5h vous comprenez
pourquoi vous n'avez eu personne au
téléphone la politique maintenant avec
d'abord les travaux du comité directeur
du parti socialiste travaux importants
puisque tout au long de la journée
les socialistes ont décidé de définir la
position qu'ils adopteront à l'égard des
communistes alors du nouveau nalco pain
lait faisait sur le fond pas grand chose
de changé le comité directeur du parti
socialiste a confirmé finalement les
propos tenus tous ces jours ci par
monsieur mitterrand et qui peuvent se
résumer en ces quelques principes
premièrement les candidats socialistes
appliquerons ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler depuis longtemps la discipline
républicaine c'est à dire le désistement
entre les partis de gauche
dans ce cas-là désistement unilatérale
en attendant que le pc lui prenne sa
décision et pour le ps le désistement
entre partis de gauche est un principe
qui ne doit pas faire l'objet d'une
négociation autre chose l'actualisation
du programme commun pour être reprise
mais dès le lendemain du deuxième tour
il n'est pas question d'un marchandage
entre deux tours de scrutin
mais il ya quand même une porte une
petite porte qui était entrouverte
c'est à dire que si le parti communiste
décider de lui-même
au lendemain du premier tour ou
éventuellement avant d'appliquer le
désistement réciproque
le parti socialiste envisage une
rencontre possible qui ne porterait pas
sur l'actualisation du programme commun
mais qui pourraient aboutir une
déclaration commune des partis de gauche
s'engageant à gouverner ensemble se
déclarant prêt à gouverner ans aurait
appelé d'une position qui sera peut-être
éclipsé demain dans les gros titres des
journaux par la déclaration de françois
mitterrand à cette même occasion sur le
franc une déclaration très durs à
l'égard du pouvoir je vous laisse
écouter la déclaration qu'on s'amusait
en face à cette offensive sur notre
monnaie nationale le gouvernement n'a
pas fait ne fait pas son devoir occuper
à battre campagne
il n'a réagi que par des déclarations
irresponsables attribuant l'origine de
la crise à la confiance croissante que
les français mettent dans la gauche tout
se passe
comme si le gouvernement et les partis
qui le soutiennent pensait avoir intérêt
à l'échec de la france devant la carence
du gouvernement je m'adresse
solennellement au président de la
république a fait au delà d'une
déclaration de principe sans portée
il rappelle au gouvernement le devoir
que la constitution lui fait en son
article 20 de déterminer et de conduire
la politique de la nation
les pouvoirs publics disposent de
nombreux moyens pour agir contre la
spéculation
ils peuvent faire comprendre aux
intermédiaires agréés sur le marché des
changes
leurs responsabilités au regard de la
nation ils peuvent réduire de 8 à un
jour comme en grande bretagne les délais
d'achat de devises au comptant
pour les socialistes il n'y a pas un
franc de droite et un front de gauche il
y a le franc de la france sa valeur doit
être défendue sans défaillance car il y
va du pouvoir d'achat des français et de
l'indépendance économique du pays à une
polémique en tout cas très trésor à noël
copains alors que lille à la
signification de cet appel au point que
je crois qu'on peut lui trouver
différentes significations différentes
explications la première c'est que
monsieur mitterrand et qui emploie lui
même le terme solennelle vais donner
finalement 7 ce qui était jusqu'ici une
polémique très dur entre lui et le
premier ministre
un caractère plus solennel et plus grave
en s'adressant au chef de l'état
deuxième explication au deuxième
signification et sans doute monsieur
mitterrand at il voulu montrer que le
président de la république était le
responsable suprême et que c'est lui qui
avait précisément la responsabilité
d'éviter qu'il y ait une catastrophe
monétaire au moment où le pays
changerait de majorité et changerait de
gouvernement une autre explication
encore on a l'impression que monsieur
mitterrand engage déjà un dialogue avec
le président de la république par dessus
monsieur bart un dialogue qui pourrait
préfigurer leur dialogue futur si
monsieur mitterrand était appelée à
occuper des responsables des
responsabilités gouvernementales
et enfin et pour monsieur pour monsieur
mitterrand c'est l'occasion de rappeler
nouvelle fois vous l'avez entendu le
principe du l'article 20 de la
constitution c'est le gouvernement qui
détermine et qui conduit la politique de
la nation
là aussi c'est sans doute une
préfiguration de sa façon de concevoir
son rôle de chef de gouvernement plus
tard et venturi voyez-vous malgré cela
c'est une déclaration de raymond barre
qui nous arrive à l'instant une
déclaration qui juge les déclarations de
françois mitterrand singulière à
montbard indique qu'il n'a pas attendu
l'appel du premier secrétaire du ps pour
redonner des 2 février d instruction ou
werner de la banque de france
et il ajoute la stabilité notre monnaie
sera mieux assurée par la politique
conduit le gouvernement que par celle
que propose monsieur mitterrand le
france et ailleurs pour parler de lui à
continuer aujourd'hui à se ressaisir un
exemple le dollar était coté aujourd'hui
à 488 contre 492 avec la politique ce
sont aussi deux événements qui vont se
maintient en direct sur cette antenne
d'abord ce soir notre émission cartes
sur table à 20h30 tout de suite après ce
journal jean pierre elkabbach et alain
duhamel accueilleront jacques chirac le
président du rpr jacques chirac qui se
déplace beaucoup en province mais qui
parle assez peu sur les antennes sont
donc des déclarations qui sont assis
attendu attendu à un moment où il semble
que la majorité reprennent du poil de la
bête c'est en tout cas ce que nous
apprend un sondage publié tri que
publiera l'aurore demain 47% pour
l'opposition 45% pour la majorité il y
avait quatre points d'écart au sondage
précédent
les socialistes perdent 1 point le rpr
et le p r en gagne un les communistes ne
bouge pas en sièges cela donnerait quand
même encore neuf sièges d'avancé pour la
gauche
et puis une annexe à ce sondage 46 % des
français contre 35 approuve le discours
du chef de l'état à verdun sur le doubs
précisément valéry giscard d'estaing
sera demain soir à 20h30 c'est l'invité
antenne 2 mais aussi tf1 répond en effet
aux questions d'alain duhamel qui
dirigera le débat et de quatre de nos
confrères jean pierre jaulin europe 1
edouard sablier de france inter i fuck
you de l'express et puis josette alia du
nouvel observateur quand la galanterie
aurait dû m'inciter à la cité en premier
ça débat de politique étrangère prévu
pour 40 minutes
on devrait y parler des relations est
ouest
du plan français de désarmement et
peut-être de l'algérie
donc demain à 20h30 sur notre chaîne
pour être tout à fait complet avec la
politique sachez enfin que les jeunes
giscardiens qui organisait aujourd'hui
la journée nationale du lycéen ont reçu
du ministre rené haby l'assurance que
l'éducation nationale on reverrait
certaines modalités d'un dossier
contester le dossier scolaire
et puis que monsieur georges séguy a
lancé il ya soir un appel à gentil dans
la région parisienne un appel donc aux
travailleurs pour qu'ils concentrent
leurs suffrages sur les candidats du pc
cgt a par ailleurs annoncé aujourd'hui
son indice des prix pour janvier 1 % de
plus qu'en décembre selon la centrale
ouvrière et voilà je tire un rideau sur
la politique
l'enquêté sur l'enlèvement du judex à
lyon à un tiers soir ne semble guère
avoir progressé en tout cas
officiellement ce rapt demeurent
inexpliquées cela dit on comprend le
besoin de discrétion des enquêteurs tant
il est vrai que le dossier lyonnais
d'une façon générale par est épineux est
compliqué on s'accorde à essayer de
l'ouvrir sur place
ah je le voyais vous le voyez aussi et
on n'entendait pas on va essayer de
revenir en contact avec avec lyon
toujours rien bah tant pis je crois
qu'on va repasser
l'enquète sur l'enlèvement du juge d'aix
en fin de journal à moins qu'un coup de
téléphone la traîne le contraire
d'accord bon
trois jours après la découverte d'un
laboratoire clandestin de drogue dans
une région que l'on croyait
définitivement nettoyer la région
marseillaise
voilà qu'aujourd'hui un rapport publié à
genève aux nations unies un rapport de
l'organe international de contrôle des
stupéfiants nous apprend que les
filières détruite se reconstitue très
peu de temps après dans d'autres régions
prenez par exemple ce que l'on appelle
le trafic de fourmis de petits trafics
il y a deux ans les fourmis
s'approvisionnait surtout à amsterdam
aux pays bas et aujourd'hui le secteur
est trop surveillé et ses petits
trafiquants préfère bangkok bangkok ce
n'est pas si cher 2000 francs pour un
aller retour par charter et bien c'est
là-bas que la brigade français des
stupéfiants est à les extirper le mal à
sa racine
si les trafiquants français les faire
arrêter soit au départ de bangkok soit à
leur arrivée à paris
est-ce qu'il ya énormément de gens qui
se font prendre plus particulièrement
les français c'est à dire que des
français où ça il ya environ un million
de touristes par an sur ce million de
tourisme de toxicomanes occasionnels qui
parce qu'ils viennent dans un talent
énorme fume un peu ou
vous essayez un peu l'héroïne île à
l'autre côté vous avez des gens qui sont
des voyageurs plus ou moins permanent
ont été en a été un peu partout puis
qu'ils viennent également taille énorme
pour encenser un paradis aussi pour les
drogués royal était ce pas tout à fait
la vérité
un petit trafiquant anti drogue et qui
part de bangkok sur 800 grammes
d'héroïne salière assez peu de chose au
fond ils risquent combien de prison ici
entre entre cinq et dix ans sur la
pression des pays occidentaux et plus
particulièrement des états unis et
thaïlandais ont renforcé les contrôles
aéroports de bangkok
les douaniers un uniforme blanc toujours
impeccables sont aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus pointilleux il n'hésite plus à
fouiller contrairement aux années
précédentes tous les bagages à main qui
leur semblent suspects même si la
réputation de la caille taille
empruntent les bagages des vols charters
sont particulièrement surveillés sur
tous les vols qui se dirige vers
l'europe via les pays arabes
les billets sur ces compagnies ne sont
pas vendus plus de 2000 francs
aller-retour ce qui permet aux passeurs
de voyager facilement
on va prendre l'exemple peut-être les
plus raffinées les chaussures par
exemple elles sont à talons compensés
c'est la mode en thaïlande est bien là
dedans
ils sont grands les talons va devancer
creux on transporte un kilo de brown
sugar de l'héroïne numéro 3 les disques
maintenant lorsque l'on passe à la
douane avec des disques sous le bras on
n'attire pas l'attention parce que le
douanier peut toujours regarder le
disque et 10 rebonds effectivement ce
sont des disques en fait à l'intérieur
on transporte un kilo d'héroïne puisque
c'est creux pour évidemment la langue ça
c'est classique
elle est creuse on peut transporter à
peu près 2 kg d'héroïne à l'intérieur la
can elle attire plutôt la pythie
qu'autre chose en fait elle écrase aussi
et puis une toute nouvelle technique
celle des bouteilles alors dans ses
bouteilles avec une seringue et qu'un
tout petit trou retire l'alcool et on
réinjecte de l'eau auquel on mélange de
l'héroïne numéro 4 on peut donc
transporter un kilo d'héroïne numéro 4
diluée ce qui est quand même très très
important et puis le clou de ce genre
d'opération c'est l'éléphant alors avec
l'éléphant qui est exportée en grand
nombre de thaïlande vers le reste du
monde
on peut le bourg et puisqu'il est creux
complètement creux de cannabis de
marijuana a donc les convoyeurs la
plupart des amateurs sans expérience
vivent tous à bangkok dans le même
quartier et dans le même hôtel le
malaisien donc dans ces conditions les
trois quarts se font piéger très
facilement
le chauffeur de taxi et leur propose
quelques grammes d'héroïne et soit un
indicateur soit à l'intermédiaire dans
les deux cas là où le jeune européens
rendant le cycle infernal de nombreux
français se comprend vous êtes fait
prendre avec ans mais l'héroïne surjoue
200 militants qu'est ce que ça
représente 200 mg en volume ça
et pour 200 mg vous avez risqué combien
de prison il n'y a pas de norme en
thaïlande
c'est à dire que j'aurais pu voir six
mois un nom c'est une question d'argent
oui j'ai payé pour aller en liberté
provisoire et ceux qui ne sont pas
capables de réunir une caution qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est à dire que restera en
prison jusqu'à ce qu'il a fait lors des
vingt ans ça peut
vingt ans pour un piège inexplicable et
que l'expérience est hanté par des gens
de tous bords
la dernière victime un opérateur sur
machine électronique un homme à la vie
rangée
il ne savait pas il s'est fait piéger il
est au fond d'un cachot à bangkok
c'était son premier voyage en thaïlande
nos petits problèmes de sons avec lyon
sont maintenant avis voici donc le
reportage que nous envoie donc françois
cornet de lyon reconnaît qu a surtout
mené son enquête dans le milieu des
magistrats là bas
retrouvez noël d'aix avec une balle dans
la tête ses ravisseurs vont ils le
libérer sans rien demander en échange
c'est ce que se demandent les magistrats
et la police lyonnaise
quarante huit heures après cet
enlèvement d'un juge at on voulu se
venger ou tout simplement intimider ceux
qui à lyon jugé requiert la police
quadrille l'abîmé face aux picards les
quartiers où noël texte pourrait être
des temples elle espère ainsi forcer les
ravisseurs accusaient leurs cages pour
essayer de les intercepter à la
préfecture du rhône
l'état major de crise composée de pierre
douay préfet de région de noël chaix
préfet délégué pour la police du justin
est chargé de l'instruction du dossier
noël text du procureur général de lyon
charles champeil et du procureur de la
république bruno ans prochain se réunit
deux fois par jour pour faire le point
sur cette enquête difficile à lyon on se
demande après la mort du juge françois
renaud et l'enlèvement d'un autre juge
noël d'aix ce qui ne va pas dans cette
ville le préfet délégué pour la police à
lyon répond
il n'y a pas une seule grande affaire à
l'exception je le reconnais une affaire
renault et de cette affaire-ci qui
débute qu'ils n'aient été élucidées et
il y a et nous n'avons pas aucun de nous
magistrats policiers autorités
préfectorales n'avons aucune crainte et
de nourrissons aucune espèce
d'appréhension à l'endroit du milieu
criminel lyonnais cas quelque niveau
qu'ils puissent être pour le préfet de
police de lyon le milieu ne tient pas le
haut du pavé ici mais les assassins du
juge renaud identifié court toujours
faute de preuves aujourd'hui c'est un
autre juge qui est enlevé un juge qui
était d'un tempérament et d'un
comportement totalement opposés à ce
françois renault en somme un juge
tranquille alors à lyon on s'étonne
andrée soulier qui connaît aussi bien le
juge noël d'aix que le milieu lyonnais
ne comprends pas l'anti lentilles
effervescents le calme le discret le
convenable monsieur d'aix il n'y a pas
d'explication
si l'on enlève aujourd'hui un magistrat
de cette qualité de cette couleur alors
on enlève tout le monde
oui et c'est inquiétant car le juge
d'aix c'est presque monsieur tout le
monde
les magistrats eux n'entendent pas se
laisser intimider
devant cet enlèvement
il est certain que les malfaiteurs
cherche à intimider les magistrats eh
bien je tiens à dire très fermement
qu'il n'y parviendront pas les
magistrats vont continuer à accomplir
leur devoir comme ils l'ont d'ailleurs
toujours fait avec objectivité et avec
détermination sans peur et sans crainte
sans qu'un la justice quand les
magistrats de lyon le milieu veut se
faire de la publicité comme les
terroristes lorsqu'il enlève quelqu'un
personnellement et là je n'engage
absolument que moi bah je suppose que le
milieu veut s'implanter à lyon et qu'il
n'y ait pas encore aussi implanté qu'il
le désire et que par conséquent pour
faire ses preuves
eh bien il emploie des méthodes comme
celle que dont nous constatons la
présence maintenant avec les enlèvements
et les assassinats poids ce qui se passe
à lyon
cette ville où le milieu essaie
d'imposer sa loi
cette ville où un juge a été assassiné
parce qu'il faisait dit-on trop bien son
travail
cette ville où un autre juge a été
enlevée voici 48 heures cette ville que
l'on a surnommé chicago sur rhône
cette ville où police et justice
entendent bien ne pas se laisser
intimider par ce milieu
malgré l'assassinât françois renaud et
malgré l'enlèvement de noël d'aix
l'étranger maintenant je vous avais d'il
ya deux jours cannois al sadate étaient
très déçus de la teneur de ses
conversations avec jimmy carter
l'exécutif américain restant semble-t-il
sous un prénom sa date s'est alors
tourné vers le législatif vers la
chambre des représentants et là bas hier
soir il a lancé un appel pressant pour
la livraison d'avions américains
l'egypte et c'est vrai que l'egypte
aurait bien besoin en ce moment d'un
renouvellement de son armement
anouar el sadate veut des armes pour
deux raisons techniques et politiques
techniques d'abord il faut se souvenir
que l'egypte a rompu avec son
fournisseur attitré l'urss
au lendemain de la guerre du kippour en
73 les réticences des soviétiques à
livrer des pièces de rechange en plein
combat ont poussé l'egypte à cette
rupture
elle cherche désormais de nouveaux
fournisseurs et se tourner vers
l'occident ou de 74
la france lève l'embargo sur les armes à
destination du proche orient et les
premiers mirage arrive en egypte
de même britannique et américain par
l'intermédiaire de l'arabie saoudite
livre également des armes l'armée
égyptienne commence à disposer d'un
matériel nouveau mais nettement
insuffisant car en 78 le gros des armes
égyptienne et surtout l'aviation reste
soviétique mais c'est un matériel qui
n'est plus renouvelée et pour lequel il
n'y a plus de pièces de rechange voilà
pour les raisons techniques
autrement plus importantes sont les
raisons politiques
en demandant des armes et surtout
américains s'adapte ne cherche pas à
déclencher une autre guerre au proche
orient mais d'abord à restaurer son
crédit comment dans le poker difficile
qu'il a engagées avec les israéliens
pourrait-il être et rester crédible à
leurs yeux s'il n'est pas
potentiellement capable comme il l'était
en 73 de se battre avec eux au moins
d'égal à égal crédible sadate aussi a
besoin de l'être vis-à-vis de son armée
qui le sert fidèlement depuis 73
mais surtout et enfin vis-à-vis des
autres pays modérés d'afrique pour qui
l'egypte reste encore un modèle à suivre
en effet au congrès sa date s'est posé
en défenseur du camp occidental en
afrique
autant de raisons qui devraient pousser
les états unis à lui donner satisfaction
narita c'est le nom du nouvel aéroport
international de tokyo si vous voulez
l'équivalent de roissy avec quand même
cette différence et qui n'est toujours
pas en service car depuis quatre ans une
poignée de manifestants écologistes et
autres empêche qu il soit terminé leur
dernière trouvaille vous allez le voir
construire une tour en bout de piste
pour gêner la circulation aérienne
ne pensez pas qu'il s'agisse du
scènes de films moyen-âge nous sommes
bien au japon en 78 ces soldats qui
montent avec leurs boucliers à l'assaut
d'une forteresse de béton et d'acier
ce sont des policiers anti émeutes
depuis deux jours ils sont 800 qui
cherche sans succès à déloger ces
nouveaux samouraï une coalition de
paysans d'écologistes et d'étudiants
opposés à l'aéroport construite en bout
de piste la tour vise précisément à
empêcher tout atterrissage et malgré
leur véhicule blindé c'est canon qui
déversent des torrents d'eau glacée les
policiers n'ont toujours pas réussi à
venir à bout de la poignée d'opposants à
simple épisode dans une guérilla qui
dure déjà depuis sept ans qui a coûté la
vie à cinq personnes et qui a retardé de
quatre années l'ouverture du nouvel
aéroport international de tokyo
nouvelles irrégularités dans le vote des
français à l'étranger c'est ce
qu'apprend aujourd'hui le canard
enchaîné le quai d'orsay dit qu'il ya
bien eu irrégularité au gabon mais qu'il
s'agit d'un cas unique conseil des
ministres aujourd'hui au menu des
ministres entre autres le dossier de la
forêt française c'est une suite au
rapport établi par bertrand journey en
matière de forêt les français sont
gâtées chaque français disposent en
moyenne de 30 ares de forêt alors que la
moyenne européenne n'est que de 12 ares
par habitant au total en france 14
millions d'hectares soit le quart du
territoire national et pourtant c'est
une richesse ignoré et inexploité ainsi
l'industrie du bois et ses dérivés pâte
à papier ameublement par exemple
représente un déficit de plus de 7
milliards de francs chaque année dans
notre commerce extérieur exemple la
france achète à l'étranger 40% de sa
pâte à papier en suède au canada
pour bertrand de jouvenel chargé depuis
soixante fèves d'étudier le secteur en
crise
la forêt française souffre de deux maux
principaux pas de gestion cohérente du
patrimoine
et puis mauvaise coordination avec les
industries qui utilisent le bois exemple
le rôle limité dévolu à l'office
national des forêts
un office national des forêts d'abord ne
doit exploiter les forêts domaniales et
les forêts communales qui le forment
ensemble que le tir de la forêt
française
d'autre part l'office national des
forêts qui est un établissement public
dont la loi dit mais qu'il est à
l'établissement public destination
commerciale et industrielle n'a pas le
droit de faire du commerce même loi le
dit il n'a pas le droit de créer des
usines des établissements industriels
comme je souhaiterais qu'il le fit fin
de nouveaux d'aller une nouveaux emplois
au bois la première action va donc être
économique
le gouvernement va par exemple essayer
de renforcer les industries
utilisatrices du bois exemple des prêts
d'une baisse de 1 milliard et demi de
francs pour la pâte à papier
autre exemple des contrats de croissance
avec les industries de l'ameublement
deuxième type d'action elle est
écologique
il s'agit de protéger la forêt qui
existe déjà mais qui est menacé par
exemple la forêt méditerranéenne
la troisième action enfin et social il
s'agit cette fois d'accroître le rôle de
la forêt dans le cadre de vie exemple
améliorer l'accueil du public ou
aménager le tourisme en quelque sorte
permettre aux français de profiter de
leurs forêts mais aussi leur faire
prendre conscience d'une richesse qu'ils
ignorent et puis toujours à ce point
ministre une nouvelle convention des
chirurgiens dentistes
il prévoit parlons des honoraires imposé
pour les prothèses et une revalorisation
des tarifs des soins conservateurs de là
dedans elle va maire vous en a parlé
dans ces la vie à 18h40
et puis dernière décision de se concéder
miss la nomination d'une nouvelle
déléguée à la condition féminine vous la
voyez elle s'appelle jacqueline non non
elle succède donc à l'école pasquet qui
est devenu l ce que tu avais tu as l a50
à l'historien à jacques chastenay mort
hier à paris il avait 84 ans était aussi
un ancien diplomate et à un ancien
journaliste s'était enfin l'un des 40
membres de l'académie française
contaminé ce journal je reviens l'espace
de quelques secondes aux affaires
sportives
figurez vous qu est ce qu aux français
sont en pleine forme elles se sont
complètement éveillé
plus tard bien sûr puisque le chemin du
monde c'était la semaine dernière
perrine pellen a aujourd'hui gagné de
belle façon le slalom spécial du camp
d'art à saint gervais vous la voyez et
al a pris sa revanche sur la championne
du monde autrichien les actionnaires
encore une bonne performance pour les
françaises puisque fabienne serra elle
est arrivée troisième voilà cette neige
m'appelle à la météo m'amène à la météo
le froid devrait demain s'accentue sur
la moitié nord est du pays et même
jusqu'au massif central attention aux
gelées le matin dans le sud est bien le
froid c'est beau ailleurs le ciel sera
nuageux et il y aura des chutes de neige
en montagne en basse altitude
les chiffres du loto qui viennent de me
parvenir à l'instant vous le voyez le 8
le 10 le 11 le 27 33 il nous manque le 5
également numéro complémentaire le 47
voilà je vous quitte vous avez deux
rendez vous jacques chirac tout à
l'heure à 20h30 en cartes sur table et
gérard holtz à 22h30 je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée à demain